want to warn you this is very disturbing
video metro is investigating reports
that a dog was killed and hung from a
fence at the seagull suites near boulder
highway and u.s 95
joe mueller is there live with the story
joe
[Music]
yeah metro just left the scene here
within the past hour or so i
watched as animal control officers took
what appeared to be a dog in a bag
from right outside of this fence outside
of this seagull suites here
animal control also left the scene just
a short time ago police say this call
came in as a dog found dead
hanging from a fence a person was taken
into custody
when i arrived that individual was in
the back of a police unit here
it's unclear when exactly this all
happened animal rights advocate gina
griesen
came soon as she heard about what
happened i believe the dog was tied out
and
baked to death my understanding is the
dog was tied out
yesterday and was discovered dead today
metro says their animal cruelty
investigators were dispatched to the
scene to help with this investigation
they would not say what type of dog
it was that was killed here now back out
here live a representative from seagull
sweet
says this happened right outside of
their property here and says they are
furious about what happened again one
person was arrested according
to metro we're still waiting to get some
more information from the metropolitan
police department i did speak to a
representative from there a short time
ago who said they should be releasing
more information
very soon reporting live here at boulder
highway near u.s 95 joe mullen 8 news
now